education to me education is it if you
don't know how to read if you don't not
a writer you know not a spell didn't
life is tough you people having real
problems in these different
neighborhoods you're gonna feed your
kids are you gonna go to school you're
gonna pay your rent are you gonna go to
school and I understand that because
I've been there but I want people to
know that the bus represent change
change itself changing community
changing everything I want them to see
that this bus is something different and
anything is possible
[Music]
I grew up in Sunnydale projects in San
Francisco it was just me my brother and
my sister my mother had to work a lot
but she did overnights this is really
rough neighborhood and as I grew up a
lot of people started fighting selling
drugs doing drugs so I started selling
drugs and robbery prostitution and
dropped out of school
to do what I want to do then one day my
son he asked me you didn't go to school
why I gotta go to school so I start
thinking about changing my life I went
to a lady who was in our community and
she said what's a program coming called
five keys you can learn how to read and
get your GED or a high school diploma
it was like everything just start
falling in place from that point I start
going going going going until I learned
how to read I graduated in 2015 had the
cap and gown on a walk down they played
the little music
it was almost the happiest day of my
life and I said okay now that I
graduated I got my high school diploma
can't get a job and they made a position
for me that's what I am now the
community ambassador and so now I'm
giving back and I'm helping other people
five keys mobile classroom is a
classroom on wheels it's a bus that
drives up to different neighborhoods
different projects and will spend about
three hours in each neighborhood from
there people get on the bus we will give
them their homework packets and they do
a work subtract that number yeah and
then you get the answer so did you know
if I have a problem calling you yeah we
started operating on a few years ago and
every since then we have a lot of people
to come on a bus I guess you can call it
like an education desert there's not the
facilities there's not the
infrastructure and it's difficult for
students to get to where there are
classrooms so it was designed with that
in mind and the fact that the bus is
unique there's a sense of pride with
that that okay this is maybe a community
that is been historically underserved
but now we have something that no one
else has like a team we serve everyone
from different walks of life and we have
people that's working that's not working
we have people from age 16 to 116 it
doesn't matter
some people come with their kids
some people come straight from work some
people come before they have to go to
work they put a lot of time and effort
in because they really want the
education hi Sheila
my role on this bus is to go out to the
different neighborhoods and not gonna
make my stores I'll go wherever they
need me to be because I'm that person to
try to get them in and try to keep them
in five keys you know anybody need a GED
or high school diploma right there that
big green bus totally free I'll call
them I'll bug them I'll text them I'll
email them whatever it takes I just want
you to get your education that's it I
didn't even know how to read a book to
my son all right I got four kids and my
oldest is 30 I let them know my story
like I couldn't read so don't be ashamed
that you can't read that you can't do
math that you dropped out in fifth sixth
grade it doesn't matter just come on
back and we got you I can show you
better I can tell you okay nice meeting
you guys see you on Thursday you took
god bless
it'd be hard in the morning getting up
but guess what it's worth it because you
come here to learn things that you never
learn or never knew and that same person
is this encouraging thing it's like you
know I've been ready for like I'm going
to school I feel like a big kid that's
like you know dropped out of school in
the sixth grade since then it has been
one heck of a ride I always had some
excuse as to why I couldn't get it done
but in whether North escapes now we're
working on algebra and I'm looking
forward to graduating at the next
graduation this bus has impacted
hundreds of lives in these different
neighborhoods it makes me happy to see a
mother or father
come on this bus with their kids and
push through it
I don't want them to feel like we're
just another program they came in the
neighborhood and now we're gone because
we're here we're here to stay so that's
why I keep going cuz I want them to know
that it we're real God gave me a second
chance and I want to show people that
they can get a second chance too
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]